hey tonight the tropicana is going to
welcome back one of its most iconic
shows one of the strip's most iconic
shows
legends in concert yeah and tonight will
end the show's longest intermission in
its 38-year history of course all caused
by this pandemic
hector mejia live inside the tropicana
with a sneak peek good morning hector
good morning this is so exciting this
means a whole group of performers are
going back to work taking the stage
including celebrity host frank marino
the whole gang really and elvis and you
know we've been wondering what elvis
has been doing since the pandemic oh
there
there is good morning sir how are you i
feel like a king
you look like one thank you very much
can i get an autograph i mean that thank
you very much
yeah sure you bet it's been a while
since my hand's written in the autograph
how about a musical autograph for the
ears are you awesome
tonight do you miss me tonight
are you sorry we drifted apart
thank you very much that is beautiful
but we have a whole hour left
what time is it now 6am matt tell us
okay so
thank you for joining us so early in the
morning how are you feeling and
congratulations and welcome back
yeah we're just so excited to be back i
mean it's been what 14 months
15 months i'm not sure something like
that around the same
around the range yeah i lost track of
time but we're so excited to be back the
town is opening up
legends in concert uh you know we've
been doing rehearsals
and it's it's like um just like riding a
bike you know but just just the lights
and the live band and just
to be able to see people and interact
again we're so excited
when you take a step back and you think
about everything that happened over the
last year
what comes to mind i mean historic night
for you guys
yeah well you know we didn't really
expect to be off
for so long and then as entertainers i
mean that's
our passion is to entertain and get in
front of people and
uh you know we that was just stripped
from us we did a couple of
you know virtual events but uh
when i heard that legends was coming
back three days a week thursday friday
saturday starting tonight
i was just so excited to get this thing
going again and open this town back
up and lastly i should i should mention
you were just sharing with me how long
you were a part of the cast for before
you guys were pushed off stage by the
pandemic yeah so i started in
1996
in in branson missouri and been with the
show for
25 years so that's that's quite quite
some time i should be getting a gold
watch i think well congratulations for
the milestone a gold watch and a gold
chain
and a gold hat so there you go
legends and concert returns tonight and
they have a great deal for locals when
you show your id
you buy a ticket and you get the second
one for free
reporting live this morning hector mejia
and
elvis presley guys